carrying pretty much
everything he owns he stops at an island
in the middle of the rio grande
the border between mexico and the united
states
he turns back to his wife and baby
nervously negotiating the rocky riverbed
swinging his child onto his shoulders
and holding his wife's hand
they make their way
they're from haiti it's probably taken
weeks or months to get here
now finally they're steps away from
america
they know they'll be detained and
they'll claim asylum
but these final steps could be the start
of a new life
to them any legal issues are worth the
risk
in just a couple of days we've watched
dozens cross like this
they wait for the river flow to drop and
in broad daylight they cross
mainly their families
the united states border patrols on and
off the river are constant
armed officers riding air boats scan the
banks looking for migrants attempting to
cross
but in the days we've been here we
didn't see them intercept
anyone mainly we watched as they
searched
with helicopter support hovering
overhead
in truth they just can't stop the
crossings happening
we came across two families on the
riverbank preparing to cross
haitians once again they've been in
mexico for three months
but have decided to make them
and what are you hoping will happen when
you get to america
objectifying
foreign
this group and unaccompanied minors from
anywhere are pretty much guaranteed to
enter the migration
processing system others are usually
just kicked back
but that said tens of thousands just
like these people
are trying to get in every single month
but it's easy to see where the migrants
gather before they cross the united
states everywhere's
full of rubbish there's also paperwork
on what to do when you get to america
interestingly there's also abandoned id
cards that are here
worth remembering too that it's not just
men going across its families as well
we have a pile of unused nappies here
and a colouring book for children and
that's really important because
since january this year 50 000
unaccompanied minors
haven't attempted to make this really
quite dangerous crossing
fernando hernandez is from honduras he
is just 16 years old
he's traveled 2 000 miles by bus to get
here
he's doing this he says for his family
and why did you leave
us to attempt the crossing but turned
back
he can't swim 2 000 miles
but 50 meters short for now
the draw of the united states and the
lengths people are prepared to go to to
get here both legal and illegal is
staggering
they're breaking records right now but
in reality
no administration has ever found a way
to stop it
and possibly never will stuart ramsey
sky news
on the rio grande in mexico